Prima di iniziare con l'episodio di oggi, ti devo raccontare una breve storia triste.
Lo script che stai per ascoltare è pronto ormai da più di due settimane e secondo le
mie previsioni avrei dovuto registrarlo sabato 19, tuttavia al piano sopra casa nostra che
anche l'ultimo stanno facendo tutta una serie di lavori di ripristino e fin qui tutto ok,
starai pensando che il problema sia al massimo il rumore ma in realtà ovviamente di sabato
e domenica non si lavora e da questo anche la mia scelta di registrare nel weekend.
Il problema però è stato che i geni dell'edilizia che stanno "lavorando" al cantiere, hanno
ben pensato di rimuovere il tetto di una parte dell'appartamento prima di impermeabilizzare
la parte sottostante.
Ora, se anche tu stai pensando che questa sia una mossa degna del criceto più stupido
della cucciolata non posso che darti ragione, anzi posso solo aggiungere che si tratta ancora
più di una cazzata se nei giorni successivi è prevista un'allerta meteo gialla per temporali.
Risultato di tutta questa genialità all'opera?
Beh, semplicemente hanno allagato metà del nostro appartamento, camera da letto, studio
e soprattutto la cabina armadio, cioè il posto dove io normalmente registro pensieri in codice
perché c'è l'acustica migliore di tutta la casa.
Ora, senza volerla portare troppo per le lunghe, la questione è che la risoluzione del problema
è ben lungi dall'essere in vista, quindi mi sono detto che se aspetto che tutto sia
sistemato, prima di pubblicare altri episodi passeranno mesi, quindi ho deciso di provare
a registrare in un'altra stanza, purtroppo l'acustica è peggiore e arrivano i rumori
della strada, ma io davvero non ho altro modo.
Detto questo, non ci resta che ringraziare questa gente e la loro inettitudine e goderci
l'episodio di pensieri in codice.
Raramente ci pensiamo, ma i numeri casuali sono una componente fondamentale della nostra
vita quotidiana, sia digitale che non.
Sono utilizzati ad esempio in campo scientifico, in informatica, nei giochi d'azzardo e persino
nella letteratura o nella musica, sicurezza, machine learning, simulazione, videogame,
le applicazioni sono infinite.
Per questo motivo la generazione di numeri casuali è impiegata in una enorme varietà
di software ed è disponibile pressoché in qualsiasi linguaggio di programmazione e per
qualsiasi piattaforma, ma in pratica come vengono generati dei numeri casuali?
Beh, il discorso in realtà è più articolato di quanto possa sembrare e di conseguenza
è molto interessante, quindi oggi ne parliamo insieme e proviamo come al solito a mettere
in fila un po' di ragionamenti e curiosità, ovviamente però dopo la sigla.
Facciamo così, proviamo a fare un gioco, pensa ad un numero a caso tra 1 e 10, quello
che preferisci con 1 e 10 compresi, non c'è bisogno che fermi la riproduzione e ti lascio
io qualche secondo per decidere ma non troppi, mi raccomando, fai veloce, giusto qualche attimo,
un numero a tua scelta tra 1 e 10, ancora un istante, ci siamo quasi, stop, deciso, bene.
Ora, secondo me ci sono buone probabilità che tu abbia scelto il numero 7, ho indovinato?
Se ho indovinato, sicuramente ti starai chiedendo come io abbia fatto, sappi che né sono un
mago né spio i tuoi dispositivi, se invece ho sbagliato ti starai chiedendo, ma perché
ha detto proprio 7, beh, in entrambi i casi la risposta è semplice, la realtà è che
la maggior parte delle persone messe di fronte alla scelta di un numero casuale tra 1 e 10
scelgono il 7, è una cosa assolutamente naturale e dietro tale scelta c'è un ragionamento
inconscio del tutto arbitrario ma che risulta tutto sommato piuttosto verosimile e che pertanto
influenza realmente la decisione, possono cambiare i dettagli ma il ragionamento è
più o meno il seguente, i numeri da 1 a 10 sono la sequenza 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, giusto? Ora, 1 e 10 sono gli estremi e quindi non hanno proprio l'aria di essere
una scelta casuale, no? Quindi li scartiamo. I numeri pari poi sono numeri più amichevoli
dei dispari nella vita reale, più facili da dividere per due, più rotondi, morbidi,
in generale sembrano la scelta più facile, non quella casuale, quindi eliminiamo anche
loro. Ci restano allora 3, 5, 7 e 9, ma 5 è esattamente nel mezzo e pari a 10 diviso
2, nemmeno questo ha l'aspetto di un numero scelto a caso, giusto? E lo stesso discorso
vale per 9, che è uguale a 3 per 3, poi non è primo, insomma non ci piace? E dunque,
la scelta resta tra il 3 e il 7, ma il 3 è così evocativo, quante volte usiamo 3 nella
vita rispetto a 7? La trinità, i tre moschettieri, le trilogie dei film, le tre grazie, potremmo
andare avanti all'infinito? È una scelta troppo facile, non ci stiamo proprio impegnando
se scegliamo 3, e quindi? Quindi alla fine resta solo 7. È la scelta che nella nostra
testa risulta meno ovvia e di conseguenza quella che sembra la più casuale, ed ecco
perché pur non eseguendo consciamente questo ragionamento o uno simile, la maggior parte
delle persone alla fine sceglie proprio il numero 7. Se pensi che io stia delirando,
ti lascio un paio di link in descrizione, puoi approfondire per conto tuo e magari condividere
anche le tue scoperte sul gruppo Telegram di Pensieri in Codice, tu trovi sul sito pensierincodice.it,
ti va. Ad ogni modo la cosa interessante di tutto questo discorso è che potrebbe sembrare
che in qualche modo il numero 7, tra quelli compresi tra 1 e 10, abbia una sorta di caratteristica
casualità intrinseca. Se lo scelgono in tanti avrà un qualche livello di casualità
maggiore degli altri, no? Beh in realtà no, assolutamente no, una cosa del genere non
vale per nessun numero. La prima cosa da capire quando si parla di numeri casuali è che la
casualità risiede nella sequenza delle scelte e non nel singolo numero scelto. Quando poco
fa ti ho chiesto di scegliere un numero, tu potresti aver scelto 7 o 3 o 5 o qualsiasi
altro ma in ogni caso come posso io sapere che la tua è stata effettivamente una scelta
casuale? Non posso, per farlo avrei bisogno di altre informazioni, dovrei chiederti di
scegliere di nuovo e di nuovo e poi di nuovo ancora per un bel po di volte e solo allora
potrei iniziare a capire se le tue scelte sono veramente casuali. Se ad ogni richiesta
tu mi rispondessi sempre 3, 3, 3 e così via ad esempio, saprei che in realtà non c'è
proprio nulla di casuale nelle tue scelte. La caratteristica di un numero di essere casuale
infatti risiede non nel numero stesso ma nella sequenza di numeri casuali di cui esso fa
parte. Diciamolo anche in un altro modo, un numero singolo non è mai casuale di per
sé, quello che individua la casualità è la sequenza o se vogliamo più genericamente
il contesto in cui è inserito. In pratica 3 o 7 o qualsiasi altro numero non sono casuali
di natura ma lo diventano ad esempio nella sequenza 5, 3, 6, 9, 7, 2, 1, 10, 4, 8. Questo
almeno se intendiamo la questione nei limiti intro i quali la mente umana o perlomeno la
mia è in grado di generare la casualità. Questa sequenza infatti l'ho creata a tavolino
scegliendo io stesso ogni volta un numero tra 1 e 10 e se la valuti attentamente ti
accorgerai che non è nemmeno particolarmente casuale, io me ne sono accorto solo dopo.
Ad esempio la prima cosa che si può notare è che nessun numero si ripete e già questo
di per sé non è un comportamento realmente casuale. Se fosse una sequenza veramente casuale
le probabilità che su 10 scelte tra 10 numeri nessuno di essi si ripeta sarebbero veramente
basse in realtà. In natura, come vedremo fra poco, la casualità è qualcosa di abbastanza
strano, ma allora noi che siamo informatici o appassionati di informatica o smanettoni
di ogni genere, potremmo pensare che visti i limiti umani basti sviluppare un software
per essere in grado di generare una sequenza casuale, ma in realtà neanche questo è vero,
o almeno non è così semplice. Di software del genere ce ne sono in giro parecchi, ad
esempio ce n'è almeno uno pressoché in ogni linguaggio di programmazione, ma in effetti
nessuno di questi da solo è in grado di generare sequenze di numeri realmente casuali, il massimo
che può fare un software infatti è generare sequenze che sembrino casuali.
A differenza di quanto si potrebbe intuitivamente pensare, utilizzando solo degli strumenti
software è impossibile scegliere un numero veramente casuale o tanto meno generare una
sequenza di numeri veramente casuali. Il software infatti per sua natura opera in modo deterministico,
cioè ogni operazione eseguita da un programma è una conseguenza diretta di istruzioni e
regole definite dal suo programmatore. Basta pensare alla definizione di algoritmo per
capirlo, una sequenza finita di istruzioni o operazioni ben definite e ordinate dove ogni
passo deve essere chiaro e non ambiguo, non è previsto in alcun modo che un algoritmo
si comporti secondo dinamiche casuali, allo stesso input deve corrispondere sempre lo stesso
output, pertanto non c'è modo che un algoritmo da solo generi un numero casuale, se lo fa
è un algoritmo con dei problemi. Un software che deve generare numeri casuali quindi in
realtà utilizza un algoritmo deterministico che produce una sequenza di numeri che sembrano
casuali ma non lo sono realmente. Algoritmi del genere sono principalmente basati su una
qualche formula o proprietà matematica e possono essere anche molto differenti fra loro. Ciascuno
di essi produce un risultato simile ma con le proprie caratteristiche e peculiarità.
Uno dei più semplici, tanto per fare un esempio, abbastanza semplice da poter essere descritto
in un podcast solo audio come pensieri in codice, è il Generatore Lineare Congruenziale, o LCG,
Linear Congruential Generator. In pratica si tratta di una formula matematica che, preso
un numero in input x0 che viene definito seme, lo moltiplica per un secondo numero prefissato,
gli somma un terzo, sempre prefissato, e infine divide tutto per un quarto numero, ovviamente
anche quest'ultimo prefissato. Il resto dell'operazione di divisione diventa x1, cioè uno dei numeri
della sequenza casuale. Poi l'algoritmo prosegue a rieseguire l'intero calcolo utilizzando
x1 come numero di partenza al fine di ottenere un valore x2, e poi di nuovo parte da x2 per
ottenere x3, e prosegue così. Il risultato di questa elaborazione è una lista di numeri
x0, x1, x2, x3, etc. che non sono realmente casuali, ma lo sembrano, perché seguono una
distribuzione statistica che imita la casualità naturale. I numeri appartenenti a questo tipo
di sequenze vengono chiamati numeri pseudo casuali, e il nome pseudo casuali deriva appunto
dal fatto che sembrano casuali, ma in realtà non lo sono, perché la sequenza è perfettamente
e completamente prevedibile se se ne conosce il numero iniziale, cioè il seme, l'algoritmo
utilizzato e i numeri prefissati. Questa particolare caratteristica della sequenza numerica che
prende il nome di deterministicità è molto importante nel campo dello sviluppo software,
che permette di riprodurre specifiche situazioni, agevolando enormemente i processi di test e
di debug. Se infatti avessimo necessità di verificare più volte il corretto funzionamento
di un nostro algoritmo che sfrutta una sequenza pseudo casuale, non dovremmo fare altro che
eseguirlo ogni volta a partire da un certo valore del seme, per essere sicuri che i numeri
generati siano sempre uguali, non andando così a disturbare la nostra analisi sul resto
del codice. La deterministicità però non è l'unica caratteristica interessante delle
sequenze pseudo casuali. Come abbiamo già detto infatti nonostante non dovrebbero esserci
pattern evidenti o correlazioni significative tra i numeri generati, in realtà una sequenza
pseudo casuale è sempre e solo apparentemente casuale, in primo luogo perché è in realtà
una sequenza ciclica, proseguendo infatti a sufficienza a generare numeri prima o poi
si ottiene che i valori si ripetono in modo ciclico, in pratica scorrendo l'elenco abbastanza
a lungo esso risulta come una o più concatenazioni della stessa serie numerica. Questo fenomeno
è dovuto al fatto che gli algoritmi che generano sequenze pseudo casuali lavorano su un insieme
finito di stati e quindi una volta che si ripete uno stato precedente l'intera sequenza si
ripete di conseguenza. La lunghezza della sequenza prima della ripetizione è chiamata
periodo e un buon algoritmo dovrebbe avere un periodo molto lungo per evitare che la ripetizione
dei numeri sia evidente o che generi problemi nell'utilizzo. In secondo luogo poi una terza
caratteristica interessante è che una buona sequenza pseudo casuale distribuisce i numeri
in modo uniforme sull'intervallo predefinito, ciò vuol dire che ogni valore dell'intervallo
dovrebbe avere la stessa probabilità di essere scelto, almeno in media, lungo una sequenza
sufficientemente lunga. In altre parole se ho 10 numeri tra cui scegliere e genero una
sequenza pseudo casuale di mille elementi, ciascuno dei numeri a mia disposizione dovrebbe
comparire circa 100 volte, l'1 dovrebbe essere presente 100 volte, il 2 anche, la stessa
cosa per il 3 e così via. Possiamo fare anche un esempio pratico pensando di utilizzare
un dado. Se il nostro dado non è truccato ad ogni lancio ci saranno sempre le stesse probabilità
che esca una qualsiasi delle 6 facce, se quindi eseguo un gran numero di lanci il numero di
volte in cui apparirà ciascuna faccia tenderà ad essere circa pari a 1/6 dei lanci, se appunto
faccio mille tentativi ciascuna faccia dovrebbe comparire intorno alle 166 volte, ovviamente
non si parla di numeri esatti ma di cifre che si avvicinano alla media con l'aumentare
delle iterazioni. Infine le ultime caratteristiche degne di nota sono che un buon algoritmo che
genera sequenze pseudo casuali dovrebbe essere computazionalmente efficiente e estremamente
sensibile al seme. In altre parole la generazione di un nuovo numero pseudo casuale deve avvenire
rapidamente e con un basso impiego di risorse, specialmente in contesti come simulazioni
o crittografia dove sono richiesti milioni di numeri pseudo casuali. E infine piccole
variazioni del seme devono produrre sequenze completamente diverse, una proprietà fondamentale
per garantire che in seguito a esecuzioni diverse del codice sia rispettata la variabilità
nei risultati. Abbiamo quindi detto che il software da solo è in grado di generare unicamente
delle sequenze di numeri pseudo casuali e abbiamo descritto sommariamente come esse
sono caratterizzate. Ma per molte applicazioni reali questo tipo di approccio può non essere
sufficiente, anzi spesso non lo è. Esistono molti casi d'uso in cui sequenze pseudo casuali
non bastano a soddisfare le necessità degli utilizzatori e sono invece necessarie sequenze
di numeri che siano veramente casuali. Una sequenza veramente casuale è tale quando
ciascun numero viene generato in modo completamente imprevedibile, senza alcuna regola deterministica
sottostante. Questo significa che ogni numero nella sequenza è scelto senza alcun legame
con i precedenti o i futuri e nessuna conoscenza dei valori già generati permette a nessuno
uomo o macchina che sia di prevedere quelli successivi. Una cosa questa che, come abbiamo
appena detto nel blocco precedente, nessun software è in grado di realizzare autonomamente.
Le sequenze di numeri realmente casuali dunque, a differenza di quelle pseudo casuali, non
sono cicliche, non sono replicabili in alcun modo e non sono nemmeno equamente distribuite.
Se disegnassimo un diagramma cartesiano per rappresentare la tipica distribuzione dei
valori di una sequenza realmente casuale in cui l'asse orizzontale contiene la scala
dei possibili numeri risultanti e quello verticale, la frequenza con cui essi appaiono, otterremmo
una classica forma a campana, detta anche gaussiana o normale. Il nome normale deriva
appunto dal fatto che in natura molte variabili legate al ripetersi di eventi casuali si comportano
secondo tale modello, cioè la maggior parte dei risultati si concentra attorno al valore
medio mentre i valori estremi si verificano più raramente.
Per capirci riprendiamo l'esempio di prima del dado.
Abbiamo detto che se ne lanciamo 1 le probabilità di ottenere valori da 1 a 6 sono equivalenti
ed equamente distribuite, ma se ne lanciamo 2 contemporaneamente allora le cose cambiano.
Con 2 dadi infatti il numero 2 o il 12 avranno una sola possibilità di venire fuori come
risultato mentre il 6 ne avrà ben 5 di possibilità. Basta fare i calcoli, per totalizzare 2 dovremmo
ottenere un 1 su entrambi i dadi e per totalizzare 12 dovremmo avere 2 6, al contrario però
per totalizzare un 6 potremmo avere un 1 e un 5 o un 2 e un 4 o 2 3 o un 4 e un 2 o infine
un 5 e un 1, 5 possibilità di totalizzare 6 contro 1 di totalizzare 2 o 12. Più aumentiamo
il numero di dadi lanciati contemporaneamente e più aumenta questo fenomeno che favorisce
l'uscita dei numeri intorno alla media dell'intervallo. In natura questo è il comportamento più
comune. A questo punto insomma dovrebbe essere chiaro che per scegliere un numero veramente
casuale è necessaria una fonte fisica di casualità, qualcosa che non risiede in un
software ma nel mondo materiale. Un numero veramente casuale infatti può essere ottenuto
solo sfruttando fenomeni fisici imprevedibili e non deterministici. A differenza dei numeri
pseudo casuali generati da algoritmi, i numeri veramente casuali derivano quindi da processi
naturali che non possono essere predetti o controllati da un modello matematico. Esempi
di tali processi sono il rumore termico, il decadimento radioattivo, le fluttuazioni quantistiche
o in generale tutto ciò che è caotico e imprevedibile. Non c'è limite ai fenomeni che possono essere
utilizzati per perseguire l'obiettivo, esistono casi in cui vengono misurate le attività atmosferiche
o le particelle provenienti dallo spazio o le onde radio. Un metodo veramente ingegnoso
ad esempio è quello di inquadrare tramite una telecamera uno scaffale pieno di lampade
lava, quelle lampade con l'acqua e la sostanza colorata che si muove in continuazione e utilizzarne
le immagini come sorgente di casualità.
Ricapitolando il discorso, quindi un software da solo può generare solo sequenze di numeri
pseudo casuali, mentre i fenomeni naturali sono gli unici realmente casuali. E quindi
come funzionano i programmi nei nostri computer che generano i numeri casuali? Come si fa
ad assicurare la varietà e l'imprevedibilità negli algoritmi in cui essa è necessaria?
Semplice, si utilizza un approccio ibrido. Da circa una decina d'anni a questa parte
i processori integrano al proprio interno dei componenti chiamati generatori di numeri
casuali hardware o HRNG, hardware random number generator. Questi sistemi si basano su vari
metodi come la misurazione del rumore termico o di quello elettrico prodotti dai vari componenti
hardware per effettuare la scelta di un valore casuale. Il numero così generato dall'HRNG
è di fatto veramente casuale e nell'ambito di questa strategia ibrida viene poi utilizzato
come seme per avviare un algoritmo pseudo casuale. Un approccio del genere permette
di sfruttare contemporaneamente i punti di forza di entrambi i metodi e di conseguenza
di mitigare i punti deboli di ciascuno. Quello che si ottiene è quindi una combinazione
dei vantaggi di casualità reale dati dall'entropia con quelli di efficienza e praticità degli
algoritmi pseudo casuali. Tre dei principali svantaggi legati al dovere osservare fenomeni
fisici per generare numeri casuali sono infatti il tempo necessario, la non riproducibilità
degli eventi e la distribuzione non omogenea dei risultati, che come abbiamo già detto
si distribuiscono a campana. Invocando un HRNG per generare solo il primo numero casuale
quindi si risparmia tempo e poi basta annotarlo da qualche parte per poterlo riutilizzare
eventualmente in caso di necessità. Al tempo stesso però utilizzando tale numero come
seme per un algoritmo pseudo casuale si ottiene una sequenza che gode delle caratteristiche
di riproducibilità e di equa distribuzione nei risultati e che viene generata in tempi
molto più brevi di quelli necessari se si dovessero osservare i fenomeni fisici. Infine
utilizzando un seme veramente casuale per avviare un qualsiasi algoritmo pseudo casuale
si migliora anche la casualità risultante dall'elaborazione e la lunghezza del periodo
della serie. Insomma in definitiva l'approccio ibrido offre un risultato equilibrato tra
casualità, efficienza e riproducibilità. Esso infatti garantisce che la sequenza generata
sia sufficientemente imprevedibile e sicura mantenendo però al tempo stesso la velocità
e la praticità degli algoritmi deterministici senza dipendere costantemente da sorgenti
fisiche di casualità. Infine prima di chiudere provo ad anticipare una domanda che potresti
porti dopo aver ascoltato questo episodio. Tale domanda è "Può un large language model
generare numeri casuali? D'altronde sembra quasi che ormai essi possano fare qualunque
cosa secondo alcuni". Beh la risposta è semplice, un LLM non può generare numeri veramente casuali
e in realtà neanche pseudo casuali. Come abbiamo già detto più volte la vera casualità deriva
solo da processi fisici che sono intrinsecamente imprevedibili e gli algoritmi di machine learning
eseguiti su macchine essenzialmente deterministiche non hanno accesso a tali processi fisici.
Inoltre il funzionamento delle intelligenze artificiali si basa su modelli matematici e
statistici che vengono prodotti esaminando dei set di dati in fase di addestramento. I
generativi che, lo dice il nome, sono quelli in grado di generare qualcosa, non possono
comunque discostarsi completamente dalle strutture e dai pattern presenti nei dati di addestramento
e questo limita fortemente anche la loro capacità di generare numeri pseudo casuali.
E così siamo giunti alla fine di questo episodio, è stato interessante? Io onestamente ero
un po stufo di parlare sempre di intelligenza artificiale anche se almeno per il momento
sembra essere il tema più gettonato. Prima di lasciarti, ti ricordo che Pensieri in Codice
è un progetto indipendente che realizzo nel mio tempo libero e con le mie risorse personali.
A questo proposito, come ormai di consueto da varie puntate a questa parte, ti ricordo
anche che si basa interamente sulla filosofia value for value. Ciò significa che è completamente
gratuito e disponibile per chiunque senza pubblicità, ma se lo ascolti spesso vuol
dire che per te un po' di valore ce l'ha, tutto sommato. E quindi ti chiedo di restituirne
un po' in qualche modo, secondo le tue modalità preferite. Puoi spenderci un po' del tuo
tempo diffondendolo, parlandone e condividendo gli episodi. Puoi dare una mano, ci sono un
sacco di cose da fare, per esempio aprire degli account social o aiutarmi con la stesura
degli episodi o risolvere issue su progetti github. O infine puoi mettere mano al portafoglio
e fare una piccola donazione o acquistare un libro dalla mia lista desideri Amazon.
Dai libri viene spesso buona parte delle mie idee. A tal proposito, oggi ringrazio come
sempre Edoardo e Carlo per la loro donazione mensile, e poi Antonio che ha messo su uno
script in python per semplificarmi la condivisione delle notizie interessanti su linkedin. E'
a questo che mi riferisco quando parlo di progetti github. Se non lo sapessi infatti
nel gruppo telegram su mastodon e da qualche settimana anche su linkedin, condivido un
flusso più o meno costante di articoli che leggo ogni giorno e che trovo interessanti.
Quindi se la cosa ti interessa trovi il link al gruppo telegram e le info su come contribuire
sul sito pensierincodice.it, mentre trovi me come valerio galano tutto attaccato sul linkedin
o valerio galano mastodon.1 su mastodon appunto. Bene, detto questo direi che per oggi possiamo
chiudere qui, io ti ringrazio come sempre per aver ascoltato oggi a maggior ragione. Spero
che la qualità audio non verrà fuori troppo terribile anche perchè per evitare i rumori
di fondo ho provato ad impostare il gain al minimo possibile e parlare molto vicino al
microfono e niente, magari sarai tu a farmelo sapere. Io ti do appuntamento al prossimo
episodio e ti ricordo sempre che un informatico risolve problemi, a volte anche usando il computer.